[Music]
America must never again be held hostage
to foreign suppliers of energy as we
were under the obama-biden sleepy Joe
group sleepy Joe he was someplace in
Iowa today and he said my name so many
times that people couldn't stand it
anymore no don't keep saying it sleepy
guy I'm just telling you Joe Biden is
not going to be able to handle what's
coming his way anyway the president Iowa
today going after Joe Biden's record
which is atrocious
along with Barack Obama here with
reaction to all this and more Senate
Judiciary Committee Chairman you know it
just cracks me up
Lindsey Graham is with us I'm knows he's
not ready for good to see you let me ask
you what we were talking about in the
last segment and that is the Deputy
Attorney General's letter yesterday the
new developments by Judicial Watch
tonight the seriousness of which this
now has taken on here right so Horowitz
will be coming out soon I hope with his
internal review of the FISA warrant
application whether or not the court was
defrauded by the Department of Justice
and the FBI Durham is going to look at
all things criminal he's owned the case
the collusion narrative has died with
the Muller report and the corruption
narrative is growing by every day when
you find more emails like you had
tonight I often refer to your
questioning of the Attorney General
about Muller about the investigation
into Hillary about FISA abuse the
origins of the probe he gave you all the
answers and now it appears he's
implementing what seems to be an
exhaustive top-to-bottom investigation
into all things serious do you believe
when he talks about intelligence the
Deputy Attorney General in that letter
that he is referring to the possibility
of outsourced intelligence gathering to
circumvent American law maybe so maybe
getting a four
governments to do things that we can't
do which every American should be
concerned about every American should be
concerned about whether or not the FISA
Court which is a secret court was lied
to about the source of information they
used to gather a warrant every American
should be worried about whether or not
our government tried to get some foreign
government to do things that were
prohibited doing by law so yeah I think
he's very much on the case based on what
we know now closed-door testimony of
Bruce or August 2016 he warned everybody
Christopher Steele's motives it's not
verified Hillary paid for it then the
State Department meeting the one
Kathleen kavlock two weeks before the
first FISA application staunch warning
don't trust this guy he has a political
agenda call me sign the first FISA
application now we now know it's an
unverifiable document and not even its
own author stands by it how is that not
a premeditated fraud on the FISA Court
not just to take away the civil
liberties of one quarter page but also a
backdoor into the Trump campaign
transition and even presidency I could
only imagine if the names were changed
and this was about Republicans doing
what you did subscribe to a Democrat
it'd be front-page news all over the
world and the only place you can find it
is pretty much on your show and a few
other shows so I don't know how we get
around the fact that Comey tells the
president in January 2017 here's the
dossier it's less unverified in that
same document was the reason a warrant
was issued four times and under oath
Comey tells the FISA Court it's reliable
enough to get a warrant so I don't know
how you square that circle but that's
why we have Horowitz and that's what my
committee will be looking at senator
what you say is it not at this point
incontrovertible evidence that it was if
it's unverifiable and it's the bulk of
the dossier decision of Grassley Graham
memo and it's the bulk of information
that that is a premeditated fraud
against the court how is it anything
else give me any possible theory
all I can tell you for sure is that we
know that still went to the State
Department trying to get the State
Department to release the dossier before
the election because he wanted Trump to
lose and the State Department told the
FBI about this encounter ten days before
they sought a warrant we know in August
as you said before or tells the state of
the FBI and DOJ you got a watch still
he's out to get Trump I don't know how
you explain all this stuff other than
it's just a fraud on the court a
political agenda I did this to me you
wouldn't have a show shot would I be
living at your place
I would not be playing golf with you
anytime soon now my back is better not
what I wanted it to be good I will do it
again you know all right let me ask you
on your end because now we've got Durham
we've got Horowitz right we've got John
Hoover we got the Attorney General there
and and and we also have your committee
which will be leading in all of these
investigations how how deep and how far
will you go back because to me if we
have equal justice an application of our
laws it has to be in the beginning well
you got to find out how the Clinton
investigation began and how it ended was
it was renovated result well I think
it's pretty clear to me that if you want
her to win you can indict her I think
the main reason she wasn't charged with
a crime discussed two people
investigating her wanted Trump to lose
and her to win
yeah that's one million to zero doesn't
that true yeah that's a lot and weren't
the people that were voting for Donald
Trump's smelly Walmart shoppers like me
these are the but the same people did
the Clinton email investigation did the
counterintelligence investigation got
the warrant they're all the same people
amazing
we're going to be watching closely and
you have made a commitment and we
appreciate your diligence and keep it up
on this